Transcription: Stephen Amany
Relecteur: eric vautier
Si on m’avait dit, il y a dix ans,
que j’en serais là aujourd’hui,
je n’y aurais clairement pas cru.
Et pourtant, tout est parti
d’une interdiction.
Oui, je dois bien vous
l’avouer maintenant,
j’étais déjà une tête brûlée.
Bonjour, je m’appelle Shannon Izar.
Ça fait maintenant dix ans
que je fais du sport de haut niveau.
J’ai quatre Coupes du monde à mon actif
en rugby à sept, en rugby à quinze,
deux Jeux Olympiques et récemment,
un titre de vice-championne olympique.
Et je vous avoue que tout ce chemin
ne s’est pas fait sans embûches,
et tant mieux, j’ai envie de vous dire.
Tout a commencé en Allemagne où je vivais
à l'époque avec mes parents et mon frère.
Je suivais toujours mon frère,
de deux ans mon aîné,
à ses matches de rugby,
avec aux pieds ses vieux crampons
et une balle ovale jamais bien loin.
C’est tout juste
si je ne dormais pas avec.
Inutile de vous dire que je nourrissais
déjà une immense envie de jouer au rugby
mais mes parents
n’étaient pas de cet avis :
« C’est un sport de garçons.
Tu es trop frêle. »
Bon, effectivement, à l’époque,
je ressemblais bien plus à un fil de fer
qu'autre chose.
Mes parents m’ont dit un jour :
« Quand tu auras 18 ans,
tu feras ce que tu voudras. »
Il ne m'en fallait pas plus.
Je les ai pris au mot
et, depuis ma majorité,
je n’ai cessé de faire du rugby.
Et quelque chose me dit
que j'ai eu raison.
Beaucoup de personnes
ont connu cette interdiction.
Les mentalités évoluent tout de même.
Des infrastructures ont été mises en place
autour de la pratique féminine.
Ça s’est beaucoup développé.
Ça n’empêche pas,
encore aujourd’hui, d’entendre :
« Ah ! Ça existe le rugby féminin ? »
J’ai même déjà eu le droit à :
« Mais c’est qu’avec des filles ?
- Non, non, c’est du rugby féminin
mais il y a des garçons aussi. »
Bien sûr...
J’ai connu l’arrivée de la
professionnalisation dans le rugby féminin
et je fais moi-même partie
des quelques chanceuses
qui ont eu un premier contrat
de rugby à sept.
Le rugby à sept est une discipline
devenue olympique aux JO de Rio.
La plupart des équipes
sont devenues pros avant nous.
Le niveau ne cessant d’augmenter,
il fallait absolument rattraper
le wagon de tête
pour pouvoir rivaliser avec elles.
Quand on est passé d’amateurs,
jonglant entre études, entraînements,
clubs, stages, etc.
à trois entraînements par jour,
le bond tant espéré fut immédiat.
On accrochait enfin le peloton de tête.
La professionnalisation s’est faite
grâce à un entraîneur fou
et seize filles des quatre  coins
de la France
qui ont pris leurs cliques
et leurs claques
pour déménager leur vie
en région parisienne
avec un modeste salaire
de seulement 1200 euros par mois.
Il fallait être assez assez fou
pour chambouler son quotidien,
ou très passionné.
La passion, c'est ce qui nous anime.
On serait prêt à tout pour elle.
Joueuses et staff compris.
C’est se lever aux aurores,
c’est voyager par monts et par vaux,
c’est louper des repas de famille,
c’est passer un Nouvel An
en stage à Bugeat -
au fin fond de la Corrèze,
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas.
J’ai les preuves en image
mais je les garderai pour moi.
C’est aussi infliger
une charge d’entraînement
qu’on n’aurait jamais cru
pouvoir encaisser.
C’est également...
C’est également jouer avec des blessures
tellement l’esprit du jeu
est important pour nous,
tellement on a la volonté
de rester avec les copines.
C’est aussi rester solidaires
dans des moments de revendications
auprès de la direction.
Pour exemple, en 2017,
les joueuses de rugby à sept
étaient salariées
tandis que les joueuses de rugby à quinze
touchaient encore
des indemnités journalières
parce que sans contrat.
Ce qui fait qu’en trois mois de tournoi,
elles ont gagné
autant que nous en une année.
Et en plus, ça s’est compliqué
quand une partie du groupe à sept
a intégré le groupe du quinze
pour ce même tournoi.
Le reste de l’équipe,
non concerné par le quinze,
a accepté de ne pas être payé
pendant tout l’été
par solidarité avec nous
et aussi pour les nouveaux contrats,
où les salaires devaient
être revus à la baisse.
Ah, les contrats !
Il vaut mieux les lire par deux fois.
Il serait dommage de s’en vouloir
pour un oubli de tableau de prime
et ne pas vouloir faire recours.
Une fois, mais pas quinze.
Les inégalités, elles sont partout.
Je peux citer nos amis belges,
où, il y a cinq ans encore,
une différence existait
au sein même de leur équipe,
où une distinction était faite
entre Wallons et Flamands.
La passion, c’est aussi faire groupe
pour aller chercher une qualification
dans les derniers retranchements.
C’est se battre tous les jours
pour montrer qu’on vaut
aussi bien que les gars.
Oui, on est bien plus que des filles.
On veut qu’on parle de nous
pour nos résultats
et non pour la couleur de nos cheveux,
ou que sais-je.
C’est l’adversité qui nous pousse
à aller plus loin,
que ce soit sur le terrain ou en dehors.
C’est faire un pied de nez
à tous ceux qui vous demandent
de choisir entre les études et le rugby,
si ce n’est pas possible
en allant au bout des choses.
Oui, parce que le double projet
professionnel et sportif, c'est beau,
mais difficilement compatible
avec des journées qui comprennent
trois entraînements en moyenne.
J’ai fait une demande
pour rallonger les jours
mais j’attends encore une réponse.
J'ai cherché des solutions.
A défaut de trouver la meilleure,
j’ai trouvé la moins pire.
J’ai changé d’école,
qui me propose une alternance,
parce que j’ai parié sur le fait
de pouvoir bénéficier du télétravail
et ainsi gagner en efficience
et moins y perdre en contenu pédagogique.
J’ai trouvé une entreprise qui accepte
mon emploi du temps de ministre
où l’imprévu est omniprésent.
Oui, parce que c’est ça,
on a l’habitude de vivre dans le chaos.
On est un peu maso, je crois bien,
parce qu’on est toujours là, certainement.
Nos plannings peuvent changer
du jour au lendemain.
Il faut savoir s'adapter.
On devient même plus flex
que Super Elastigirl.
Et tout le monde n’en est pas conscient
et, surtout, n’est pas forcément
prêt à s’y adapter.
On développe des compétences
et on devient même plus organisé
qu’un wedding planner.
Au moins, on est prêt à l’imprévu.
Ce n’est pas facile tous les jours,
mais personnellement,
je ne conçois pas le rugby
sans quelque chose à côté.
Comme le disent les Anglais :
« Être bon sur le terrain,
c’est être bien dans sa tête. »
Thomas Lombard l’a très bien dit :
« Ça permet de garder l’esprit ouvert
pour être une personne plus équilibrée
et un joueur de rugby plus accompli. »
On peut y trouver l’inspiration,
la connaissance
et la confiance dans d’autres sphères.
Et c'est une chance, une nécessité même.
De meilleurs hommes feront
toujours de meilleurs joueurs.
Pour moi, c'est clairement
une bouffée d'oxygène.
On fait face à l'adversité tous les jours.
On peut s’y perdre
mais on apprend.
On s’éloigne parfois
de nos objectifs sportifs
mais c’est ce qui fait qu’on développe
bien plus de compétences.
Si toutefois on voulait passer
une validation des acquis de l’expérience,
on serait multi-diplômés,
surtout dans le domaine managérial.
Il faut voir le côté positif des choses.
C’est bien connu,
les femmes sont multitâches.
Et malgré tout, une différence
existe avec les hommes.
Comment pourrait-on demander
la même chose ?
On court moins vite.
On est moins explosives.
Et on est moins endurantes qu’eux.
Et pourtant, ce n’est pas faute
de s’entraîner plus.
Il y a une logique qui m'échappe.
Sans blaguer, oui, il y a une différence
biologique indéniable
parce que notre corps, il est fait
pour accueillir un enfant.
C’est bien pour ça que,
tous les mois, notre cycle arrive.
Parlons-en.
En tant que sportive,
c’est une vraie problématique
et pourtant, très peu de choses
sont faites à cet égard.
Cependant, des recherches ont démontré
qu’à un moment donné de ce cycle,
notre corps est plus sujet à subir
des blessures ligamentaires.
Et j’en sais quelque chose.
Manque de pot, la dernière en date
était pile en cette période.
La préparation
des footballeuses américaines
a été adaptée à chacune
en fonction de leurs cycles.
C'est une grande avancée.
Pareil pour enfanter,
parce que chacune est différente
et les envies le sont aussi.
Devenir mère est un sujet
qui vient tout juste d’être  mis
sur la table dans le rugby.
Les handballeuses ont montré la voie  :
une convention collective
a été signée il y a un an déjà.
Les mentalités changent,
c'est une bonne chose.
Ça s’est fait non sans mal
et non sans efforts
mais ça paye.
Ce n’est pas le cas partout.
C’est à nous, les femmes,
mais à vous aussi, les hommes,
de faire bouger les choses,
de déconstruire les stéréotypes
en s’imposant,
en montrant ce dont on est capable.
Et ça paye parce que
des efforts ont été faits.
Des ressources ont été mobilisées,
des ressources qui peuvent être partout,
dans votre entourage proche ou lointain,
dans votre passé, dans votre présent.
Et le tout,
et tout ça,
est bonifié par l’adversité rencontrée.
Donc
remerciez vos obstacles,
vos meilleurs ennemis,
et, si le cœur vous en dit, chérissez-les.
Vous êtes poussé dans vos retranchements.
Le tout, c’est de
se mobiliser et d’avancer.
C’est ce que j’appelle la résilience,
l’arme fatale pour quiconque.
La résilience, c’est quoi ?
C’est une aptitude
à faire face avec succès
à une situation représentant
un stress intense
en raison de sa nocivité,
ainsi qu’à se ressaisir, à s’adapter
et à réussir à vivre
et à se développer positivement
en dépit de ces
circonstances défavorables.
Vous allez me dire :
« Super ! Comment on fait ? »
Eh bien, je vous livre ma pensée :
développez vos ressources,
croyez en vous,
vous avez tous les outils, mais
vous n’en n’êtes juste pas conscients.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)